世間が暑すぎて・・・
物を壊したくなります。
こんにちは！→
（？？？）つるにぃです！
ﾎﾞｷﾞｨｯ!!（はじめの破壊衝動）
（つるにぃ）オ゛ヘッ！！
（はじめ）あの、この公園でよく動画撮るんですけど
（はじめ）この公園、実は球技禁止なんですよ。
（つるにぃ）そうなんすか？
（はじめ）うん多分、だから人が多いからボールとか飛んでくと危ないから
（はじめ）いたるところで・・・→
（はじめ）→・・・ボールだらけです！
（はじめ）シャボン玉はセーフだと思います
（はじめ）結局誰かに飛んでくと危ないってことなんで
（つるにぃ）そうですね
（はじめ）多分それで球技禁止になってるt
（はじめキレた）セミうるせえなぁ！！！
（はじめ）ボールって危ない・・・
（はじめ）人に当たると危ないんで禁止なんですけども
（はじめ）今日はそんな、球技禁止の公園でも遊べそうなものを準備しました！
（つるにぃ）おぉ！
（はじめ）はいこちら、知ってますこれ？
（はじめ）『スーパーバブル』
（はじめ）『不思議な強さ バブルボール』！
（つるにぃ）ボーﾙ...
（はじめ）球技じゃねこれ・・・
（はじめ）蹴れるんすよ、シャボン玉みたいなのに
（はじめ）ほら見てこの少年・・・→
（笑うつるにぃ）
（はじめ）でこれ握れるし、蹴れるし、潰せるし...
（はじめ）もうなんかすげぇ何でもできるみたいなボールです
（つるにぃ）無限大っすね遊び方
（はじめ）そうなんすよ
（はじめ）やばくね、だって破けねぇシャボン玉だよ
（はじめ）まってちょうちょが！
（恐怖するつるにぃ）ウワ゛ーーッ！！！！
（つるにぃ）無理だって虫！！
（はじめ）僕
（つるにぃ）ははｯは...
（はじめ）まぁちょっと話を盛って言うと、→
（はじめ）→です。
（はじめ）ちょっとこれで今日はつるにぃをボコしていこうと思います
（つるにぃ）いやえぇボコすｯ...
《0214mex》
（恐怖と焦りをあおるBGM）
（笑うつるにぃ）
（更に笑うつるにぃ）
《単三乾電池購入の0214mex》
（はじめ）やばい！餅みたい！
（電池を開封する音）
（はじめ）え・・・まって→
（つるにぃ）おっと・・・
（はじめ）ねぇーまってぇ・・・
（苛立つはじめ）きっつ...
（はじめ）ドライバーって書いといて欲しかった！
（はじめ）え、マジでやばいよこれ
（はじめ）ぶっ壊すかもうここを
（つるにぃ）ぶっ壊しちゃってもいいんじゃないすかね、だってカバーいらないじゃないすか
（決意を抱いたはじめ）ぶっ壊すか！
（はじめ）いきます
（叩きつける音）
（倍速で叩きつける音）
（はじめ）これやばいぞ・・・（小声）
（つるにぃ）簡単に壊れないんじゃないすか？
（はじめ）いや・・・漢なら壊す
（はじめ）それが漢だ。そうだろつるにぃ？
（つるにぃ）確かにそうですね
（つるにぃ）壊してナンボですから
（泣くはじめ）あぁああぁあああぁ～～～・・・
（はじめ）どうすっかな・・・
（はじめ）つるにぃちょっと壊してや
（つるにぃ）ここを、パカッていければいいんですよね
（はじめ）うん、そうそう
（つるにぃ）となると・・・
（再び叩きつける音）
（笑うはじめ）あっはは・・・→
（つるにぃ）一番手っ取り早い方法が、
（つるにぃ）お父さんみたいな人に・・・
（はじめ）いや待って、でも・・・
（つるにぃ）ドライﾊﾞ...
（はじめ）いっちばん手っ取り早い方法は・・・
（さらに叩きつける音）
（笑うつるにぃ）ははははははwww
《0214mex》
（はじめ）よしいくぞー
（二人）おぉぉぉおぉおあああ！！！！！！
（はじめ）これだぁー！！
（はじめ）これで75cmまで膨らませます！
（つるにぃ）いやわかんないっす・・・w
（つるにぃ）入れすぎると破裂しますよねこれ
（はじめ）ねぇもうもう、良いんじゃない良いんじゃない？
（はじめ）はい、というわけで完成しましたぁ！
（はじめ）ほんと割れない！
（はじめ）割れないしめっちゃ風船っぽいんすよこれ
（はじめ）お、お、すごいすごい！
（はじめ）え、これ蹴っていいんすよね確か
（はじめ）つねっても割れないです
（はじめ）蹴ります
ボスッ（蹴る音）
ボヨン（着地）
ボヨン（跳ねる）
（失敗）
（はじめ）ｳｧﾜ"ｧｱｱｯ!!
（はじめ）蹴っても全然割れねぇ！
（はじめの投擲）uh!
（カメラに会心の一撃）
（はじめ）ちょっと！！待ったーーッ！！
（焦る二人）
（つるにぃ）あぁぶなぁwwww
（つるにぃ）ほんとにwww
（はじめ）どんだけぶっ潰そうとしても潰れないし、
（はじめ）ぶん殴っても全然大丈夫ですし
（はじめ）ほんとすごい、なんか絶対割れないっていうのは結構ホントっぽいですね
（はじめ）これ乗っても割れないんだっけ
（はじめ）ちょっと一回乗ってみます
（はじめ）乗って割れたらオレ怒るよ。
（はじめ）じゃ乗ってみまーす。
（はじめ）うぁあ゛怖いよーーー！！
（はじめ）あ、あ、あ、すごい！
（はじめ）乗れてる乗れてる！
（はじめ）まてよ勢いよく行ったら壊れそう
ﾋｭｸﾎﾟｯ（着地する音）
（はじめ）あ゛ぁー痛った待って！！
（はじめ）ウ゛エッホェ゛（咳）
（はじめ）ウ゛ェ゛ッホコ゛ッホコ゛ｯ（咳）
（はじめ）あ゛ゎあ待ってッ
（はじめ）みんなそろそろ俺達は帰るよ
（はじめ）ありがとね。
（つるにぃ）最後の最後にィ！！
（はじめ）はいということでこれマジで壊れないんですよ
（はじめ）てことは、これひょっとしたらもっと膨らませれるんじゃねと思ったんでちょっと、
（はじめ）もうちょい膨らまして大きくしてみようと思います
（はじめ）やべーよこれ・・・（小声）
（つるにぃ）これはやばいw
（はじめ）うわ、うわ、うわ、うわ
（はじめ）マジで、待って待って待って
（はじめ）すごいすごいすごい
（つるにぃ）すごい！！
（はじめ）滞空時間がシャボン玉！
（はじめ）ほら、待って
（はじめ）え、え、すごい
（はじめ）うぉらーっ！
（はじめ）滞空時間がww
（はじめ）ﾇｩｳｫ"
♫～
（ﾎﾞﾖﾝ）
（少し息切れしてくるはじめ）
（はじめ）やべ、高い・・・
（ﾎﾞﾖﾝ）
（はじめ）あぁ、やばい高い・・・！
（はじめ）高いよ！
（ﾎﾞﾖﾝ）
（ﾍﾞｼｯ）
（はじめ）あぁやば・・・！
（つるにぃ）あぁあ゛ーははw
（つるにぃ）うぉあ
（つるにぃ）うわぁあ
ﾋｭﾊﾞﾝｯ!!!（儚く散るワブルボール）
（はじめ）あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛あ゛！！！！！！！
♫～エンディング
（4:26あたりの頭突きは17コンボでした）